deuxième salle de contrôle d'identité
ici pour la queue 68 du mouvement à des
gilet jaune certains gilet jaune se sont
rejoints tout à l'heure non loin de
l'assemblée nationale un lieu qui avait
été interdite par la préfecture de
police les forces de l'ordre ont donc
verbaliser certains d'entre eux une
première fois puis ont tenté de les
disperser ils se sont retrouvés à
quelques mètres de là à la station de
métro à solférino deuxième savent donc
de contrôle d'identité vous pouvez le
voir actuellement à derrière moi il ya
quelques instants faouzi lellouche l'un
des organisateurs de ce rassemblement a
été interpellé nous l'avons rencontrée
avant ainsi que l'avocat david lieb skin
je vous propose de les écouter
je suis pas tout seul à avoir envie de
parler au chef de l'état mais c'est
surtout pour lui dire les quatre vérités
face à face les yeux dans les yeux parce
que je pense que en tant que chef de
l'état il a cette responsabilité de
dunes de ne pas avoir répondu depuis 15
mois à la grogne sociale et de ne pas
avoir apporté ce que les gens
attendaient d'avoir fait comme si
ce qui se passait ça n'avait pas lieu
c'est à dire tous ces gens qui ont été
blessées qui ont été incarcérés il ya
beaucoup de gens incarcérés mais surtout
des gens mutilés
les idées je ne peux circuler lui part
dans paris
l'espérance que
revient quand même à des bonnes
décisions alors c'est d'autant
surprenant plus que le président de la
république a dit prêt à recevoir une
délégation de gilet jaune et la
répression enfin quand quand je continue
donc il ya quand même un côté assez
paradoxal et à un contradicteur voilà
qu'il faut noter donc en bas on va
attendre de voir ce qui se passe lui en
tout cas toute façon il y aura sans
doute une plainte qui sera déposée
les forces de l'anp sont actuellement en
train de procéder à la dispersion des
personnes qui ont été contrôlées
ici certains parlent de se retrouver
ailleurs
d'autres parlent de rejoindre à la
manifestation qui est actuellement en
cours et qui devrait arriver au champ de
mars en dessous de la tour eiffel à
paris